Pete: So tell me about the next layer of your
architecture.
You're doing some interesting things on the
data side using NoSQL technologies and other
things.
Talk to me a little bit about that.
Dag: For every single bid request we get in
we actually have to do some sort of storage
lookup.
And the way that is done, actually we have
several, usually two look-ups per request.
So, if we're doing 25,000 requests per second,
then we have to do about 50,000 look-ups.
And also, we do store information about them,
so we have also fairly substantial write throughput.
And this is like one of those obvious situations
where traditional, very general, database
technologies fall through.
We could probably scale the reads pretty well
up to that amount.
But the writes would be very, very hard.
And also, because we're so latency constrained,
having a general database engine to add 2-3
extra milliseconds is just a waste of time.
Pete: So because of this, how many different
types of data stores do you have?
Dag: So, we have three types basically.
We have the key value storage, which is used
for reads and writes during the time critical
bidding process.
Then we have traditional RDMS which is, in
that case MySQL, that we use for the more
business oriented, the standard things that
are nice to put in a database.
So, we have our, well, ledgers and transaction
logs for money flow.
Not for the high frequency stuff, but for
the more low frequency stuff.
And then we also have a more big data type
store, which we use for doing analytics and
queries on.
The really, really big data sets.
We actually have a fourth.
We also have our unstructured, or they're
actually structured, but we have just raw
logs that we can run more with MapReduce ad-hoc
queries over if everything else fails.
Pete: And I think we spoke previously.
You're looking at some different solutions
for NoSQL data sotres.
Talk to me a little about the options there.
Dag: Yeah, there are a lot options for an
NoSQL right now.
And, so first of all I like the new explanation
for NoSQL, which is “not only SQL”.
And this is all about finding the right tools
for the job and the different NoSQL solutions
are usually very specialized.
There are some general ones like Mongo and
CouchDB that are fairly general NoSQL solutions
and they also they have sweet spots but in
our case we were looking at something very,
very simple.
We just actually have key and values, that's
all we need.
Something with extremely low latency and something
that performed consistently and predictably.
And we looked at a number of different projects
including open source projects have actually
started running on open source projects.
I'm not going to bash them right now, but
we ended up actually going for a commercial
vendor.
Which I'm not going sell either right now.
Well, yeah.
They're called Citrusleaf.
It's a really good company, actually.
They deserve a lot of credit.
They took a lot of the jitter in our performance
just right out the equation, out of the equation.
So, very, very simple yet very capable NoSQL
solution that performs insanely well.
This is the stuff that we're running on our
SSD drives in a fairly small cluster, but
can still take immense, the throughput is
awesome.
Pete: So you mentioned that there's faster
technology out there than the typical MapReduce,
Hadoop stack, that many engineers are becoming
familiar with.
Talk to me a little bit more about the options
there, and what you guys are looking at.
Dag: First of all, MapReduce is just a principle
on how you can process or split big data into
smaller chunks and then process in parallel
and then try to reduce it into something meaningful
in the end.
And there are a lot of generalized MapReduce
frameworks, the most of well known one is
called Hadoop, which is basically a rather
large stack of software which is founded on
the principal of MapReduce.
We started using Hadoop.
It does have some strengths as in that, it's
open source and it's fairly easy to get started
with.
We've had some issues running into bug It's
fairly difficult to get everything up and
running there.
But it worked all right.
But we were seeing, for the things we do,
we need shorter response times.
We needed to do queries over really large
data sets, and we just found out that Hadoop
didn't perform well enough for us.
We were using Amazon's elastic MapReduce framework,
or their cloud offering, which also works
pretty well, but it just didn't give us the
performance we wanted.
And the fundamental reason for this is probably
or at least into large degree that when using
Hadoop and you are using raw log files underneath.
You actually have to, if you have thirty terabytes
of data, then you have to read thirty terabytes
off a disc.
Whereas, very often, you just want to pick,
let's say, one of the queries we might run
over this data set, you want to see how, what's
our over the course of a month, how many ad
impressions could we sell to iPhone users
in North America, and all we're interested
in them is the platform.
We detect it and maybe some IP ranges or DMA
or something like that.
But, just a couple of fields.
Pete: So you're talking about selecting a
value out of just one column, out of a data
set that might have many columns in the row.
Dag: Yeah.
So, that's exactly it, right?
And so Hadoop is brute forcing a lot of these
things.
What you really want to do is just, well,
this is just like the poster-boy for column-oriented
databases.
There are a few open source ones there, too.
So, HBase is one, but Cassandra is probably
one of the more well-known there.
HBase then Cassandra.
There is an interesting project going on I
know that the Datastax guys are doing, with
running Hadoop on top of Cassandra, which
then, at least, takes away the storage and
load, I/O, problem out of the equation.
But it turns out that there are a lot of proprietary
commercial vendors here, that offer solutions
that still just blows anything else out of
the water.
Some of them are actually hybrid open source
as well like Infobright it's based on MySQL
and has a proprietary storage engine.
And has a communication, but you actually
have to.
If you want it.
We're not using them, but if you want these
solutions you actually have to pay for them.
At least for now.
And then they use compression, column-oriented
storage, and they just, it's.
I recommend anybody that's looking for analytics,
and especially real-time analytics, to take
a look at these offerings.
I know that if we were trying to do this with
something like Hadoop, well, we would have
made it work.
We could do rollups on a regular basis, all
those kinds of traditional workarounds for
it, but with these solutions you can actually
just run your queries and SQL and they will
respond in sub second even over hundreds and
millions of rows.
Pete: And a couple of those players again
are?
Dag: So the ones that we've been looking at
are Vertica, Infobright, Aster Data, Greenplum.
and another player called VectorWise, which
is from Ingres.
So, they all perform incredibly well.
They do start to change a bit when you start
doing.
So, we have two types of big data basically.
We have the impression tracking, which is
based per campaign.
That's still in the region of maybe a couple
hundred million rows that we do analytics
on.
And then we have this firehose, which is in
the thirty billion row region.
And when you start getting up to those levels
they start to differ a bit due to the way
they're architected, some are easy to scale
out where as others actually have to be scaled
up.
So they're different, but they're all worth
a look.